The third part of
Memorial Hall, which
is to the right of the
transept, is Sanders Theater.
And this is a place that so
much history has happened in.
Churchill spoken there.
Marcel Marceau has
performed there.
John Gielgud has
Booker T Washington received
an honorary degree on the stage
there.
During my presidency, we had
a remarkable special ceremony
to give an honorary degree
to Teddy Kennedy, who
had been diagnosed
with a brain tumor,
so we wanted to hurry up
and give him his degree.
And it was just a
wonderful celebration.
And it meant so much to him.
And I can still see him.
I left the stage and he
was supposed to follow me.
And he didn't want to leave
at the end of the ceremony.
And I remember turning around
and seeing his silhouette
as he looked out at
the cheering audience.
And the cheers would not stop.
And he would not leave.
And I'll always keep that
image of the entire Sanders
audience and Teddy Kennedy
silhouetted in front of them.
A number of wonderful
undergraduate courses
are taught there.
Michael Sandel's Justice course.
I remember attending a session
of Tom Kelly's first nights
course.
It's also been a place
where wonderful concerts
and theatrical events
have taken place.
Wynton Marsalis, who
gave six concert lectures
over a period of three
years several years ago,
performed all of
them in Sanders Hall.
And I remember he said that he
loved performing in that place
because the wood paneling
made it seem as if he
were playing inside a violin.
And so the acoustics
were really special.
So when I think
about these three
parts of Memorial
Hall and the vision
that the Civil War era
alumni had for this hall
to be a core of campus life,
but also a uplifting place that
would raise the spirits
of the institution
and make the institution think
about its highest values,
I think we've done a pretty good
job of carrying that forward
into the 21st century.